[Music]
now in my life I have seen some crazy
[ __ ] but this by far is one of the
craziest things I've ever seen in my
life the other night I was chilling my
bed we just got done filming JK news and
then Jo Texas me the [ __ ] I like on some
Instagram post I clicks it and I see the
most gangster [ __ ] I've ever seen in my
life
we in the house y'all i'ma go here watch
I check over there
Oh what's up they got some chicken feet
a hot dog oh my god that's crazy they
got a crazy up in here [ __ ] who is you
you better get your way my walk I'm the
Grim Reaper [ __ ] you run [ __ ]
[ __ ] you want some of this [ __ ]
die I'm a West Side [ __ ] [ __ ]
tic-tac-toe don't [ __ ] with this oh yeah
one for good measure [ __ ] ha that's
right run back from the [ __ ] you came
from [ __ ] now if you guys don't
know about this basically there's this
asian lady who gets her home invaded and
she unloads on these [ __ ] and
I'm not talking about just a random
invasion I'm talking about there was
three dudes that came into the house had
guns with about the [ __ ] it up now
before we start this article I do have
to address something it's very
interesting when I run with the comments
when a video like this or an article
pops up and then the amount of stupidity
is amazing so the title of this in a
certain article that I read was gangster
Asian lady unloads clips on bla bla bla
bla
now people got hung up on a certain word
in the title guess what word that was
the word was gangster and specifically
what people were saying how dare you
title her at a gangster Asian lady she
is not a gangster she's not an
affiliated gang listen here you dumb
piece of [ __ ] stir when used in that
context doesn't mean that she's an
affiliated gang member it means that the
Asian lady handled her [ __ ] she was dope
as [ __ ] what the [ __ ] don't you
understand and listen I get it not
everybody hears a lot of slang I guess
but when there are people under your
common explaining to you what it means
and it's not just the person who wrote
the article it's everybody else telling
you what it is how can you stay Adam and
I'm saying no it was a misleading title
I thought it was a gangster hey do
yourself a favor take a spoon and stick
it up your butt look what the [ __ ] are
you talking about when I enjoy food I
call it gangster awesome gangsta his
dumplings are you saying my dumplings
are gang affiliated
a were you that stupid why don't you
suck my [ __ ] and the reason why this
article made me happy not because she
shot people and because somebody died
even though they did invade her home and
they were trying to [ __ ] [ __ ] up because
she protected her home and on top of
that I
heard so much growing up that Asian
women are submissive what the [ __ ] are
you talking about I did a vlog about
this a while ago but here is proof this
woman unloaded a gun not with two hands
but with one and at the same time was
talking on the phone did you hear the
911 [ __ ] was insane they coming my help
with a gun and so what I do I kissed him
a [ __ ] S&S r.i.p
could you imagine what she was like as
an Asian mom your thumb do your homework
one mommy to bust a cap in your ass be
abcdefg under yama don't [ __ ] with me Oh
mommy gonna get some big kunai anybody
who ever says that Asian women are weak
in any kind of way you have never been
raised by an Asian mom I think I once
got beat because my fart smelled like
what what did you expect it to smell
like it's why I guess his lady lives in
this house with this other guy who by
the way didn't really do much but that's
okay
in a situation I probably took the same
she gets a gun they have a firing
altercation she blasts away three of
them scatter one person gets shot in the
torso and he passes away you guys ever
wonder in these type of situations what
you would do even if you had a gun
because nobody really expects to get
their home invaded right which is why
that topic comes up why people have
firearms in their homes for protection
and in this case it really worked out
for her now for me I'm trying to think
about what would happen if I was in that
situation and I kind of think I would
have just got robbed because personally
I don't really condone violence
do yourself a favor take a spoon and
stick it up your think a lot of the
times too like in our head we always
think about hey this is what I would do
in that situation but when it comes to
the time it doesn't really work out that
way one time when I was in elementary
school I had watched so many kung fu
movies of a guy just standing in the
middle just super strong post thinking
to himself
today you [ __ ] with the wrong guy I'm
guy and as he makes his speech the first
guy comes in he just three seconds later
everybody's knocked the [ __ ] out now
during this time I was about to get
jumped by three people in my mind I
played it out just the same way the only
difference was at the end of the scene I
had my underwear up into my ass
cracked a black eye and they stole my
bubble mamma bubble tooth gum was a
Bubble to bubble mint either way I got
[ __ ] up so I'm kind of wondering what
would you guys have done oh I'm trying
to get some dick tonight
[Music]